we've got some breaking news now and
details are emerging about three British
men who are being held in Taliban
custody in Afghanistan they include
so-called danger tourist miles Rutledge
who returned to the country after being
evacuated by British armed forces less
than two years ago he's on the right
there the other two men are charity
medic Kevin Cornwall pictured here and
another unnamed UK National who manages
a hotel in Kabul they are believed to
have been held by Taliban secret police
since January a foreign office
spokesperson has said we are working
hard to secure Consular contact with
British Nationals detained in
Afghanistan and we are supporting
families
let's speak to Scott Richards from the
presidium network who's helping the
family of Mr Cornwall and the unnamed
man Scott thank you so much for talking
to us what is your understanding of what
happened to those two men we have a very
clear understanding of the the course of
events that day having spoken with
multiple Witnesses uh to the events
including people in the room when the
search has taken place so what we
believe uh our critical basis is that
the GDI which is the Taliban
intelligence reacted to a tip regarding
a weapon stored in the in the premises
uh that weapon was licensed and we
believe that during the course of the
search that the license may have been
separated from the weapon and this
circumstances ultimately the extension
of a misunderstanding
what conditions are they being kept in
and are they in good health
um to our knowledge and awareness
um we do believe they are in good health
and being well treated we have no reason
to believe they've been subject to sort
of
um any any negative treatment such as
torture
um and we're told that they are they're
as good as can be expected in such
circumstances and have authorities been
able to make contact with either of the
men no not to this point there has been
no meaningful contact there's been no
access by International monitoring
agencies such as icrc which would
normally be allowed to see people in
prison prison or detainee conditions and
there's been no other form of access to
the individuals today
and what were they doing in Afghanistan
uh the first individual Mr Cornwell is a
paramedic uh and he was liaising with
organizations such as the United Nations
world food program and UNICEF uh the
second individual as you stated in your
introduction was a manager of the
facility where uh Mr Cornwell and many
other expats stay
and what is your relationship to their
family and to these men Scott uh we were
looking into the position of detainees
uh in Afghanistan and allegations of
people being held uh during which we
discovered the presence of these two
individuals uh at that point we then
contacted the family to assist them in
terms of uh speaking about the issues
but also with our long-standing
relationships in Afghanistan and myself
having previously had familiar with
Rarity with Taliban uh that we could
assist in the negotiations to secure
their release
what's the General Security situation
like in Afghanistan and specifically in
Kabul
um that's a very complex question to
answer you would normally if you take
the taller bar online they will say that
security is improved obviously we've
witnessed a number of iskp attacks uh
the more concerning part for foreigners
working is that when we have a situation
such as arbitrary detention and no right
of legal access no Clarity of legal
process that certainly makes it much
more complicated and risky for anyone
looking to conduct humanitarian Aid at
this difficult time for the country and
that's really one of our key concerns
even above and beyond the lack of
security is the lack of transparency on
process in these kinds of circumstances
so where does this go now Scott if the
authorities have not been able to be in
touch with these two men what happens
now
uh we're very hopeful that contact will
be made
um we ourselves at presidium have
engaged in conversations uh and in and
around uh with the Taliban to help
facilitate and clear up this matter as
which we said we believe is a
misunderstanding uh and a
misunderstanding that comes from not
being familiar with the processes and
practices of contractors operating in
hostile zones
is there something that makes you
particularly hopeful if they've been
held since January and nothing's
happened since then
um
hope in the sense that we've been able
to I think Express the situation we've
documented the situation we've collected
the evidence uh behind the surrounding
circumstances
um that we believe adequately
demonstrate that this is a
misunderstanding and that given this is
also the holy period of Ramadan that
compassion could be shown by the Islamic
Amer as a tradition of this period to
Pardon individuals
so do you think when it comes when Eid
comes around you could see a pardon
we would be hopeful and we would
certainly request the Taliban consider
this situation in the context of their
pursuit of you know trying to bring an
investment trying to turn the country
around trying to
um
manage a situation we have massive
malnutrition they fundamentally need Aid
they need the world food program and if
those people are not able to operate
safely
um or risk of a legal system that is not
wholly defined or understood it's
problematic for those people to be there
so we we certainly hope they see the
wisdom uh that there is in looking at
these situations carefully and
thoughtfully
other large number of foreign National
in Afghanistan at the moment yes
there are and they come from many many
different countries there is a lot of
momentum happening around Kabul at the
moment and it's a very very Broad and
diverse sector from a western
perspective they'll mostly be in
humanitarian sectors though
assume that if you go in
Unitarian you go in with an agency you
get the protection of that are there
foreign Nationals who go in without that
protection
um
the way the the
the agency's work and this is very
important because there's limitations on
what United Nations and other entities
can do because there is no constitution
in Afghanistan which is a prerequisite
for those entering so therefore they
subcontract large bodies of the work to
be done and performed by a smaller
humanitarian agencies so they're
contracted to the larger International
Aid organizations which doesn't which
means they don't get the protections
that one might assume if you work for
say udama the United Nations mission in
Afghanistan or if you work for un
directly
how total is Taliban control of the
country
uh that's a complicated question
um the Taliban have concentrated their
influence in power in the South but the
Taliban can't be understood as a single
cohesive element
uh they're accomplishment of many tribes
um so their their focus has always been
their traditional areas such as Kandahar
and Helmand
as to the influence with any
concentration of power it will change in
dimension as you get to towards the
North
what's your message to people
without the protection of an agency
at this point in time it would be unwise
for anybody to enter into Afghanistan
um but doesn't understand the culture
that doesn't understand these things
because it can change on you very very
quickly many people have been there for
years believe they have a good
relationship or they understand things
but in the circumstances where you're
left in a situation where there are no
clear legal Avenues and you don't
understand what's happening it's it's
not somewhere you want to be so it's not
a recommended action for anyone
um as I think the state department and
the UK government says but this is also
reason why we would hope that Taliban
increases transparency on their process
with regard to rule of law
okay Scott thank you so much for talking
to us